how did you meet this investor yeah and
um
how does it actually work i think as i
shared with you before we went on to
this i think a lot of people
always i don't know i feel like from the
conversation i have just have a quite
sort of negative view of
if i if i go with an investor i'll go
with someone that's going to support me
start my recruitment business aren't
they going to take all my money
well i started looking it was actually
for a rec to wreck um
[Music]
and it put me in touch with a few
different investors and
i also wanted to i also wanted an
investor that
could um lead me to my own devices a
little bit and i was prepared to back me
when
when you know i'm not really asking any
questions
first of all it's been it's been it's
been really exciting i feel like
2g is like reborn again but i kind of do
feel like that a little bit i felt like
i've
i've got my got my edge back not i think
i may have lost it but just in a
different way
yeah um so yeah it's been an incredibly
exciting journey
that to get back into a position where
you're actually recruiting i've always
loved
um to recruit um it's it's it's always
got to be extremely excited about having
a project to be able to fill that
project